Ich beziehe mich auf den vorherigen Vortrag von Dr.
Blues on Cans Konzeption der Freiheit, und
mein Vortrag wird sich mit dieser Diskussion
über seine Theorie der Freiheit befassen, unmittelbar
nachdem seine zweite Kritik
1788 erschienen ist, während viel Forschung
auf dem Gebiet der krebstheoretischen
Philosophie betrieben wurde, der in
letzter Zeit immer mehr Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt wurde  Historischer
Kontext und Auswirkungen der Can't Practice-
Philosophie Paul Gaia hat betont, dass
es in diesem Zitat reichlich Raum für weitere
Forschungen im Hinblick auf die Wurzeln und die
Rezeption von Kants Philosophie gibt,
insbesondere seiner Moralphilosophie,
und natürlich hat DITA Henry erklärt, dass
wir dieses Zitat brauchen  einer umfassenden
Auseinandersetzung mit den Zusammenhängen der
Freiheitsauffassung und natürlich die Figuren
rund um die Rezeption der Cons
Praktischen Philosophie sind nicht nur
notwendig, um den
historischen Kontext der Cons Praktischen
Philosophie zu verstehen, sondern diese Zahlen sind auch
für das Verständnis der
Entwicklung von Bedeutung  der Cons-Theorie des freien Willens,
aber Cons-Theorie der Freiheit nicht  nur
von Interesse für die Kant-Forschung, da
Konzepte wie Determinismus im
Determinismus, Indifferentismus oder
Kompatibilismus in diese
Debatte eingeführt und in einer Weise verwendet wurden,
die der zeitgenössischen Debatte sehr ähnlich ist.
Mein Vortrag befasst sich mit einer Reihe zentraler,
aber weniger unbekannter philosophischer
Beiträge  kin Theorie der
Freiheit und ordnet sie in den
historischen und systemischen Kontext ihrer
Zeit ein, dokumentieren diese Texte die intensive
Kontroverse, die im
unmittelbaren Kontext von Kahns kritischer
Philosophie nach der Veröffentlichung
seiner Kritik der praktischen Vernunft im Jahr 1788
in meinem Vortrag, den ich vorstellen möchte, entfacht wurde  und analysieren
wichtige Beiträge zu dieser Debatte
beginnend mit der frühen Rezeption
seiner Moralphilosophie durch den
wenig bekannten Johann Heinrich Auguste Willy
in seinem Buch Lotteriekunde Deutsch
eleuterio loogie über Freiheit und
Notwendigkeit und endend mit beschussphilosophischen
Untersuchungen über das
Wesen des Menschen  Freiheit von acht
eenhundertneun Ich werde jedoch argumentieren,
dass es in der Post-Kanga-Debatte nicht so
sehr um das Problem geht, wie
Freiheit mit den Naturgesetzen in Einklang gebracht werden kann,
sondern um das Problem des
intelligiblen Fatalismus, nach dem
wir nur moralisch frei handeln können, aber  nicht
zu frei, um aktiv unmoralisch zu werden Ich zeige,
wie Philosophen wie Kalyan und
Reinhold du Gottlieb Fichte sind und
schließlich wenig Helium verwenden
, um auf die Herausforderung eines solchen verständlichen Fatalismus zu antworten.
Schließlich
zeige ich, wie diese
Freiheitskonzepte mit der Gegenwart zusammenhängen  Debatte
unter Bezugnahme auf einen christlichen Kurs
bewacht eine Theorie des Handelns und auf Harry
Frankfurts
Konzeption der Willensfreiheit
Beginnen wir mit Kant
über die Freiheit als rationaler Determinismus, also
werde ich hier in diesem Teil auf den
vorherigen Vortrag zurückgreifen und
dieses Zitat noch einmal erwähnen  ist das Zitat, das
Kant in seiner Religion über die zuzurechnende
Fähigkeit gegeben hat, von der er sagt, dass der Mensch sich
selbst machen oder gemacht haben muss  in was auch immer
er moralisch gut oder böse ist oder werden sollte,
diese beiden Charaktere
müssen eine Wirkung seiner freien Wahl sein,
denn sonst könnten sie ihm nicht zugeschrieben werden
und folglich könnte er
weder moralisch gut noch böse sein, also müssen wir
die Wahl haben, entweder
moralisch gut oder böse zu handeln, so dass die
Kommunalfrage der Nachteile eine zweite
Kritik ist, wie eine neuere praktische
Vernunft den Willen bestimmen kann, und zwar
ohne Einflüsse durch Sinnlichkeit,
die nach Kant hetero
hetero feind wären, so er  argumentiert er und stellt
er
das Fragezitat, wo die reine
Vernunft für sich allein ausreicht,
um den Willen zu bestimmen, oder ob sie
nur als empirisch bedingt Bestimmungsgrund des Willens sein
kann, so stellt sich hier die
Frage nach rationaler
Selbstbestimmung oder rationaler
Bestimmung des Willens  Will, also ist es
sehr wichtig, um frei zu sein, und
hier ist die Situation der Welt
nach Khans Bild, sagt er,
zitiere den Willen  Ich stehe zwischen seinem
apriorischen Prinzip, das formal und
auch rational ist, und einem Pop-a-
posteriori-Anreiz, der materiell
wie an einem Scheideweg ist, also ist dies eine sehr
kritische Position des menschlichen Willens,
so Karl, also ist jetzt die Frage,
wie Menschen handeln können  Jede Vernunft
motiviert und bestimmt den menschlichen Willen,
damit er moralisch gut handelt
, um frei zu sein, um
als frei bezeichnet zu werden, muss der Wille
so bestimmt sein, dass es nicht genügt,
unabhängig von empirischen
Einflüssen zu sein, er muss von besonderer Art sein  der
Bestimmtheit so sagt er in
diesem Zitat Zitat Freiheit ist nicht
gesetzlos, sondern muss eine
Kausalität nach unveränderlichen Gesetzen sein, aber
von besonderer Art, denn sonst wäre ein freier Wille
ein Unding, also von was für
Gesetzen rede ich hier  mein
jeder weiß es das das sittengesetz
nicht nur sondergesetze ist sondern ein ganz ganz
besonderes gesetz denn das sittengesetz und willen ist
nach kant eine art kausalität
von lebenden wesen  insofern das
irrationale und die freiheit die
eigenschaft solcher kausalität wäre,
unabhängig von sie bestimmenden fremden
ursachen wirksam zu sein, so haben wir hier
zwei freiheitsbegriffe positive
freiheit und negative freiheit der
positive aspekt ist diese art rationaler
kausalität der determinierte wille  Nach
zwei praktischen Gründen oder dem moralischen Gesetz ist
dies positive Freiheit, also hier ist die
Reziprozitätsthese, auf die sich der vorherige
Vortrag bezog. Ich zitiere sie erneut. Er
sagt, dass ein freier Wille und der Wille unter
moralischen Gesetzen ein und dasselbe sind, also ist
dies eine Aussage  über Identität, also wenn der
Wille frei ist, dann ist es ein anderes moralisches
Gesetz und umgekehrt ist
es dasselbe. Wenn also der Wille unter dem
moralischen Gesetz steht, ist der Wille frei, also haben wir
diese Art von Identität zwischen den meisten
Arten von beiden Arten von Willen
und es gibt  Ein weiteres Zitat,
das die Reziprozitätsthese von Henry
Ellison in 80 im Jahr 1986 genannt wird, besagt, dass
Zitatfreiheit und bedingungslose praktische Rechtsreziprozität
Beifall implizieren  hier ist die
deutsche Übersetzung allerdings
etwas schwächer, dort steht vice
and vex Eliza alpha none, die stürmt, also
beziehen sie sich doppelt gedämpft aufeinander
und daher
erscheint mir diese Übersetzung von imply etwas zu
stark  weil Implikation ein
logischer Sinn wäre und es nicht klar ist, wo
sie nicht denken können, dass es eine
Implikation in a ist, ein bisschen bedingt
auf logische Weise, zumindest können wir
es so allgemein ausdrücken, wie das
tief verbundene Sehen ist  Die Frage,
ob es sich um eine Identität handelt
, hat Henry Ellison, wie gesagt,
die Reziprozitätsthese genannt. Hier ist das
Problem aus dieser Reziprozitätsthese
folgt einem wirklich großen Problem, nämlich dem
Problem der moralischen Unreinheit und auch des
verständlichen Fatalismus, also ist dies das
Argument dafür  Konstruieren könnte man so
einerseits zunächst die Prämisse Freiheit ist
die rationale Bestimmung des Willens
durch das Sittengesetz Das Sittengesetz befiehlt
Moral daraus folgt, dass wir nur sind  y
frei und moralisch handeln und wir sind
im Handeln gebunden glaube ich nämlich durch äußere
Vernunfthindernisse etwas
Vernunftäußeres, das
nichts mit uns selbst zu tun hat, das wäre also eine
Art Heteronomie in dieser Art und
so handeln wir  bösartigerweise war
Henry Sidgwick einer der ersten
Interpreten moderner Interpreten, der
dieses Problem betonte. Er sagte, Zitat
könne Wille und Vernunft weder ausdrücklich noch implizit
identifizieren. Diese
Identifizierung schließt offensichtlich die
Möglichkeit des Willens aus, zwischen
Vernunft und nicht rationalen unreinen Impulsen zu wählen,
aber oder bereits  bevor
Kalyan noch einmal festhielt, wen ich
in diesem Vortrag erörtern werde, wies er auf das gleiche
Problem hin, also nannte Henry Ellison dieses
Problem Reinholds Dilemma
, das ist also eine Möglichkeit, es zu beschreiben. Eine
andere Beschreibung dieses Problems
ist Einwand RS  wirklich,
wirklich großes Problem der Bedingung,
also ist die Frage, wie wir frei handeln können,
wenn unser Wille von der Mora verlangt wird  Das
Gesetz ist nicht die Bestimmung des Willens
durch das moralische Gesetz aus reiner praktischer
Vernunft eine Art Notwendigkeit, denn wie
können wir frei sein, bestimmt zu
sein, sogar gezwungen zu sein,
je falscher Kant natürlich sagen würde,
das ist die  Wir brauchen eine Art von Freiheit, die
von einem inneren
aus einem inneren Prinzip erforderlich ist, nämlich aus reiner
praktischer Vernunft. Sie würden sagen,
das ist Autonomie, das ist die Freiheit, die wir
brauchen, aber hier ist die Frage, ob
die Willensfreiheit mit dieser Art von Notwendigkeit vereinbar ist,
selbst wenn sie rein ist  praktischer grund, also
der erste philosoph, der dieses
problem diskutierte und der nicht sehr bekannt
ist, war johanna august heinrich früh, und er
schrieb ein buch, in dem ich erwähnte, dass
es eine gesetzteleologie von adina aus dem jahr
1788 hieß, und ich möchte seine
position als a klassifizieren  Art transzendental im
Kompatibilismus, weil er die
Cons-Theorie diskutierte und sie auch klassifizierte, so dass
er in diesem Zitat sagt
, dass es klar ist, dass die Cons-Doktrin in keiner Weise sein muss
verwechselt werden mit in Determinismus für
in Bezug
auf Erscheinungen und Handlungen in
Bezug auf den empirischen Charakter des
Menschen, aus welcher Perspektive der In
Determinismus die Möglichkeit hat, ihn als ansteckend zu betrachten,
als die entscheidende Notwendigkeit
und jede Freiheit in Bezug auf
den intelligiblen Charakter verweigert, wie er
zu erklären wusste  sich auf so
geniale Weise, dass er auf der einen Seite
die Naturnotwendigkeit
genau nach dem Begriff vermeidet, den er zu
deutsch hat, und auf der anderen Seite den Zufall vermeidet,
dh ein Entstehen ohne jede
bestimmende Krone, aber da die
Verneinung der Naturnotwendigkeit und der
kantische Sinn nur ausschließt
Bestimmung durch Erscheinungen oder durch
zeitlich ablaufende Bedingungen
bleibt immer die Frage, ob
Gründe der Bestimmung des intelligiblen
Vermögens in der intelligiblen Eigenschaft selbst zu finden sind,
die zwar nicht zeitlich vorausgehend, aber
dennoch Gründe wären, in diesem
Fall wäre Naturnotwendigkeit zu
verstehen  in einer anderen wa  y so ist dies die
erste Interpretation des
kantonalen Autonomiebegriffs in gewisser Weise
notwendigerweise gibt es noch ein weiteres Zitat, das
ich zitiere, vielleicht ist das Weglassen der
Vernunft ein ursprünglicher und unveränderlicher Mangel
an Gründen, eine Schwäche im
verständlichen Charakter und vielleicht die
ist die Ausübung der Vernunft ein ursprünglicher und
nicht unveränderlicher Zustand einer
höheren Aktivität und Wirksamkeit, dann haben
wir eine Notwendigkeit mit der
Unveränderlichkeit des intelligiblen Charakters auch keine
natürliche Notwendigkeit und der Kangan-Sinn,
aber der empirische Charakter ist
notwendigerweise im intelligiblen
Charakter begründet  also ist auch hier Notwendigkeit,
also überall Notwendigkeit, also ist dies eine
Art Dilemma, auf das früh hingewiesen wurde.
Wenn die Naturgesetze unseren
Willen so bestimmen, dass dies erforderlich ist,
müssen wir sagen, dass die Bestimmung
des Willens durch das moralische Gesetz erfolgt  ist auch eine
Art Notwendigkeit, wie können wir also frei sein, wenn wir
sowohl von den
Naturgesetzen als auch vom Gesetz des
So-Ist-Gesetzes dazu gezwungen werden?  Es war ein Problem, also stellten wir diese
Frage, also gab es
zu der Zeit einen anderen Philosophen namens Johann Heinrich.
Unser Strand und ihm seine ein
Jahr später erschienene Arbeit, die 1789 erschien,
versuchte er gegen all diese Schlussfolgerungen zu argumentieren
, dass wir durch
das moralische Gesetz gezwungen sind und  so unfrei
interpretierte er die Bestimmung des
Willens durch die mehr allein und in einem
anderen, Kant näher stehenden Sinne,
sagte er Zitat Freiheit
soll mehr oder in einer Notwendigkeit in einem
Zwang sein, wenn dies der Fall ist, dann ist
es gleich ob  wir gehen von innerer oder
äußerer notwendigkeit aus, denn in diesen fällen geht der
begriff der freiheit keineswegs verloren,
das ist nur ein missverständnis, denn
innere notwendigkeit meint das determinierte
sein der dinge, deren intrinsisch
determinierte tätigkeit selbst, also kommt
er dem kantischen begriff der
autonomie näher  will aber das ist sozusagen
der rahmen, in dem sich die ganze
debatte um freiheit und determinismus
abspielt, nach dem can geht es mehr um
die bestimmung  des Willens durch das
moralische Gesetz und nicht so sehr durch die Naturgesetze,
hier ist die dritte Person, die ich
in dieser historischen Debatte diskutieren möchte, sein
Name war Cal Christian Eric Schmidt, und
er schlug eine Theorie vor, die er selbst
als verständlichen Fatalismus bezeichnete, also handelt es
sich hier um  die Frage, wie
der durch das Sittengesetz bestimmte Wille zu verstehen
ist, ist ein Zitat, das
er sagte, wenn insoweit Handeln
die Prägung rationaler Selbsttätigkeit sprengt oder
wenn eine gegebene Substanz
nach der Form der Vernunft bestimmt und behandelt wird,
dann sie  sind dagegen eher Handlungen unmoralisch
und soweit
von einer Wirkung selbsttätiger Vernunft keine Spur ist, so ist
dies eine Art Entbehrungstheorie des
Bösen, also bedeutet moralisch böses Handeln
eine Art Unentschlossenheit
durch a  Aus praktischer Vernunft, also ist die Frage,
was uns sonst dazu veranlasst,
auf moralisch böse Weise zu handeln, das ist die Frage,
was der Fall war, dass es
etwas außerhalb von uns gewesen sein muss, nicht etwas
Vorübergehendes  also hier ist die entbehrungstheorie
des bösen er sagt zitat unmoralische handlungen
und einstellungen hängen keineswegs von der
eigenen absoluten selbsttätigkeit ab, sondern von
der entbehrung davon
es ist eine entbehrungstheorie des bösen ist auch ein
weiteres zitat die fähigkeit zu
unmoralischem handeln ist eine folge  der
Beschränkung unserer Freiheit, die im
Hinblick auf die Begründung ihrer Unfähigkeit ist, also
mehr moralisch böse zu handeln bedeutet
,
moralisch mehr nicht handeln zu
können, bedeutet also, dass wir unmoralisch handeln, dass wir üben und
unfähig sind  oder dass, wie dies zu verstehen ist,
dies ein wenig seltsam schwer
zu verstehen ist, ein anderes Zitat in diesem
Verhalten heißt, dass der Mensch, sobald er
unmoralisch gehandelt hat, nie ganz bei
Sinnen ist, das heißt, er hat nicht die
Fähigkeit zu mehr Freiheit und das letzte
Zitat durch Kalkül  th Fleisch in seinem
Streben nach Tierphilosophie Versuch einer
Moralphilosophie Zitat Wir haben keine
Freiheit, kein Original in einem bestimmten
Grund, das Böse zu wollen, sondern sind in dieser
Hinsicht lediglich abhängig  Das ist also das
Problem, laut Schmitt sind wir nur
frei, moralisch gut zu handeln, aber wir
sind verpflichtet, wenn wir moralisch böse handeln
, also wie kann man uns vorwerfen,
moralisch böse gehandelt zu haben, das ist
das Problem
Also Kalyana Reinhold Er ist ein
bisschen berühmter, aber heutzutage nicht so bekannt.
Er versuchte, gegen diese
Art von verständlichem Fatalismus zu argumentieren, der
von Cal Christian vorgeschlagen wurde
ein Widerspruch, aber es scheint
mir das beste Etikett zu sein, um
seine Position in dieser Debatte zu verstehen, also argumentierte er
gegen MIT gegen seine Konzeption des
intelligenten Fatalismus und er sagte, zitiere
seine, das ist Schmidts Behauptung, dass der Mensch
nur im Falle des moralisch
Guten frei handelt  aber nicht in moralisch bösen Taten und
dass er unweigerlich auf den Buchstaben entschlossen ist
und mich in höchstem Maße spürt,
trotzdem muss ich die Subtilität bewundern, mit der
er seinen Sport auf
Soidiers einsetzte
Aus dem kantischen Konzept des Willens als
Kausalität der Vernunft folgt sicherlich,
dass, wenn die Moral die Tätigkeit
der Vernunft ist, die Unmoral nicht die
Tätigkeit der Vernunft sein kann und da nur die
Gründe frei sein sollen, die Tätigkeit
nicht frei sein kann, also versucht er es
Argumente gegen diese Position finden
sich zahllos und versucht dieses Dilemma zu vermeiden, dass
entweder Heteronomie
durch das Gesetz der Natur oder
verständlicher Fatalismus
durch das Gesetz der Vernunft bestimmt wird, je mehr Gesetz, also
hier ist die Antwort seiner Strategie, um dieses Dilemma zu vermeiden,
das er ist  argumentieren exzess zitieren
die Wirkung der Vernunft kann der Vernunft niemals
durch das Handeln eines Personenvirus widersprechen,
da der Buchstabe
nicht im bestimmten Verfahren der
Vernunft begründet ist, sondern in der Fähigkeit,
das eigene Handeln selbst zu bestimmen und sich
der Vernunft bewusst so zu bedienen  es
hängt davon ab, wie wir
unsere Begründungsfähigkeit einsetzen, also wie Wille und Vernunft
in besonderer Weise miteinander verbunden sind, und auch
wichtig ist, dass er sich das vorstellt
Thema Freiheit nicht in Bezug auf die
reine praktische Vernunft, wie es manchmal
scheint, sondern in Bezug auf die Person,
die einzelne Person, die
ihre Fähigkeiten wie Vernunft
oder die nutzen oder verwirklichen kann,
und hier ist eine weitere sehr, sehr wichtige
Portierung in diesem Zusammenhang, sagt er  Zitat
Wollen ist mehr als nur unfreiwilliges
Verlangen, und dass in jedem
Willenszustand eine besondere
Handlung existiert, die Entscheidung genannt wird und die sich
durch Reflexion
von der Behauptung des unfreiwilligen Verlangens unterscheidet, also
interpretiere ich diese Passage in Bezug auf das,
was Harry  Frankfort hat später
Wünsche erster Ordnung und Beziehungen zweiter Ordnung genannt,
also ist das, was er hier
unfreiwilliges Verlangen nennt, die Grundlage unserer
Neigungen oder Wünsche Wünsche erster Ordnung,
und wir müssen über
sie nachdenken, indem wir die Vernunft und
andere Fähigkeiten einbeziehen und unseren Willen durch
Handeln bilden  Bei diesen Wünschen erster Ordnung
müssen wir einige Überlegungen einbeziehen, also
versucht er auf diese Weise, Unin zu vermeiden
verständlicher Fatalismus noch ein
Zitat und hier ist hier endlich die Frage
was der Grund für unser
Handeln ist, wenn es nicht das Naturgesetz ist und
auch nicht das Gesetz umso mehr falsch ist und
hier ein Zitat das mich zur
Einstufung der Etikettierung seiner
Position als ein geführt hat  rationaler Indifferentismus,
so sagt er, Zitat, eine freie Handlung ist
grundlos, und soweit ihr Grund und
Grund die Freiheit selbst ist, aber dies
auch der letzte denkbare Grund dieser
Handlung ist, ist sie die absolute erste
Ursache ihrer Handlung, darüber hinaus
kann man nicht weiter denken  da es wirklich
von nichts anderem abhängt, zu fragen, warum
der freie Wille sich selbst bestimmt hat, und dies
oder jenes bedeutet, zu fragen, warum er frei ist
, angenommen, er brauchte einen Grund, der sich
von ihm unterscheidet, bedeutet, seine Freiheit zu leugnen, also
würde ich nicht sagen, dass es das ist  eine Art
Rationalismus, weil es heißt, es gibt
Gründe, warum es Wolf ist, aber schließlich würde er sagen,
dass wir keinen objektiven Grund
angeben können, würde er sagen, es ist gerecht
und subjektiv Pommes, also ist die Frage
w  Ob diese Unterscheidung zwischen
objektiven und subjektiven
Gründen plausibel ist, bezweifle ich. Ich würde sagen, dass
diese Unterscheidung höchst problematisch ist,
weil es immer um Gründe geht
, aber er würde am Ende sagen
, dass wir die Gründe, die uns geführt haben, nicht objektiv erklären können  so
oder so zu handeln, deshalb nenne ich
seine Position irrationalen Indifferentismus
Art Rationalismus lass uns fortfahren der
nächste Denker du willst göttlich fiktiv
ist glaube ich relativ bekannt im
Vergleich zu Kalyan Hot Vinyl oder gar
August Anglish Dummkopf oder Kalkül
aber ich würde sagen, dass wir
Victors Beitrag oder Fixierung auf die
Theorie der Freiheit nur verstehen können, wenn wir ihn
in diesen Kontext innerhalb dieser
Freiheitsdebatte stellen, die kurz nach dem Erscheinen von
cunts second critique im Jahr 1788 begann,
weil fig ausdrücklich auf
diese Debatte besonders verweist  Kali auf heiße
Luft Ich weiß, so sagte er in diesem Zitat
Zitat, wie viele Stützen der kritischen
Philosophie ma haben
von anderen hohen Erkenntnissen erlangt und auf erhellende Weise gezeigt wurde,
muss man sorgfältig
unterscheiden zwischen jenen
Manifestationen absoluter Selbsttätigkeit
, durch die sich
praktische Gründe und viel zuteilt,
und jenen anderen Manifestationen,
durch die eine Person in dieser Funktion sicher ist
von seinem Willen bestimmt
, ob er dieses Gesetz bezahlen oder nicht befolgen soll, dies ist eine
sehr, sehr entscheidende Unterscheidung, die
wir auch in christlichen Cross Guards finden.
Interpretation einer Art Moralphilosophie
offensichtlicher
Hinweis auf Reinhard und das
sind also einige der Aufgaben des Siegers. Ich
werde all diese Aufgaben nicht erklären,
die zu viel Zeit in Anspruch nehmen würden, sondern nur eine sehr kurze
Art und Weise, zuerst sagt er, dass der moralisch
Verantwortliche
als eine Einheit von beidem konzipiert werden muss  rationales und vernünftiges
Individuum, so dass er die
Individualität einer Person betont und dies
gegen Cants Vorstellung von reiner
praktischer Vernunft w ist  die manchmal
Gegenstand der moralischen Freiheit zu sein scheinen
laut Karren und er betont die
Einheit dieses Individuums dies ist ein sehr
wichtiger Punkt Die zweite Aufgabe von 50 ist,
dass der freie Wille
von der allgemeinen Fähigkeit der reinen
praktischen Vernunft unterschieden werden muss, um  Um
die Gefahr eines verständlichen Fatalismus zu vermeiden und
eine Vorstellung von individueller Selbstbestimmung zu entwickeln
, wie es Ryan Ryan
Howe in seiner Theorie der Wünsche erster Ordnung
und der Volition zweiter Ordnung getan hat, hat das meiner Meinung
nach mit dem Problem der Individualität zu tun,
was das Thema ist  Das
Individuum, das als freies
Drittes bezeichnet werden soll, muss eine spezifische Form der Rationalität und
Reflexivität des Willens
bewahren und analysieren, um
die Gefahr des
Indifferentismus oder des empirischen Determinismus zu vermeiden,
damit wäre das andere Lemma, also der
eine Hebel der rationale Determinismus oder
sogar empirischer Determinismus, der Notwendigkeit bedeutet,
nach dem sie und
das andere Lemma reiner Zufall oder
gleichgültig ist  würde auch nicht
ausreichen, um unser freisein
zu verstehen viertes moralisches Handeln ist
als etwas zu verstehen, das im
Lichte des Mehr angerechnet wird, also müssen wir
unser Handeln immer im Hinblick auf die
Forderung des Mehr rechtfertigen also wie
Kant schon sagte  Wir müssen
unseren Willen, unsere Verfassungen dem moralischen Gesetz
unterordnen oder sogar das moralische
Gesetz unseren individuellen Maximen unterordnen, aber
in diesem Abschnitt ist immer das moralische Gesetz involviert,
es ist immer diese Rationalität
involviert, also ist dies dem Cons
Account in seiner Religion sehr ähnlich  und hier ist der
entscheidende punkt, dass 50 unterscheidet, dass
50 hier ich zitierte die bloße form des
wollens macht, diese absolute forderung nach
individueller identität ist noch nicht, je
weiter das reine wollen hier nicht so
verwendet wird wie je mehr gesetz, sondern nur
zur erklärung  des Bewußtseins
kann der kategorische
Imperativ nur zur Erklärung
des Pflichtbewußtseins überhaupt nicht genügen, also
unterscheidet 50 zwischen dem  reines Ich deines
Egos und zwischen dem mehr Gesetz und dem
reinen Ego ist nicht identisch mit reiner
praktischer Vernunft, da es
nach Khans Auffassung des
intelligiblen Charakters
rein rational und sogar durch
das moralische Gesetz bestimmt zu sein scheint, also hier dies  ist eine sehr
entscheidende Unterscheidung, und diese Unterscheidung
ähnelt dem, was Christian
Horoscope in ihren jüngsten Büchern von 1996 und 2009 getan hat.
Er sagt, dass sie sagt, dass die Kant-
Theorie zu implizieren scheint, dass nur gute
Taten wirklich Taten sind und
dass für schlechte Taten nichts übrig bleibt  zu sein Ich
werde einen Unterschied machen, den Kant
nicht macht Ich werde das Gesetz
des Handelns nur nach Maximen du kannst wollen
zu sein den kategorischen
Imperativ nennen, und ich werde
es von dem unterscheiden, was ich  will the more more so nennen,
dass der kategorische Imperativ
etwas hat, das
von the more law zu unterscheiden ist, und dies
hilft ihr, sowohl die
Individualität des eigentlichen Akteurs als auch
die Möglichkeit des Handelns zu erklären  g auf eine moralisch
schlechte Weise,
die dem Zitat, das ich zuvor gegeben habe, sehr ähnlich zu sein scheint, um diesen Bericht zu fixieren,
also fahren wir fort - wirklich - wir verwenden
Schellings
rationalen Voluntarismus und echten
Kompatibilismus, wie ich es nennen möchte,
weil Schelling auch auf sich selbst zurückgreift
Merkmale und besonders in Reinholds
Darstellung der Freiheit, so gibt es zunächst
eine interessante Passage aus seinem Essay über
Freiheit und nämlich eine Unterscheidung,
die ihm hilft
, wie ich ihn lese, eine Freiheit des Willens zu machen
, die mit unserer natürlichen Existenz vereinbar ist,
sagt er, Abhängigkeit
nicht  schafft die Unabhängigkeit ab es schafft nicht
einmal die Freiheit ab Abhängigkeit
bestimmt nicht sein Sein und sagt nur, dass
das Abhängige, was auch immer es sein mag,
nur eine Folge dessen sein kann, wovon es
abhängig ist Abhängigkeit sagt nicht,
dass das Abhängige ist oder nicht ist und
hier ist  der entscheidende Punkt, jedes
organische Individuum existiert als
ein erst durch ein anderes Gewordenes und ist
insofern abhängig
von seinem Werden  ing, aber keineswegs
nach seiner Gebühr, so scheint dies
eine entscheidende Unterscheidung zu sein, die
Schelling hilft, dieses Problem der
naturgesetzlichen Notwendigkeit zu
vermeiden  Wille vereinbar mit unserer individuellen
natürlichen Existenz, so
nennt er dies organische Abhängigkeit zur
Abgrenzung
von rein naturgesetzlich bedingten Vorgängen oder Ereignissen
und entwickelt nun eine Darstellung des
Willens, die ihn auch
nach Harry Frankfurts
Unterscheidung interpretieren kann  alle Begierden
und Relationen zweiter Ordnung aber dieses
Zitat ist wirklich sehr dunkel aber ich
deute es in dem Sinne er sagt
im letzten und höchsten Urteil gibt es
kein anderes Wesen als willens sein
urdeutsches Sein, dem du allein
alle Seinsprädikate
grundlos zuordnen  bei Analogie Unabhängigkeit
von Zeit Selbstbejahung
strebt die gesamte Philosophie nur danach
diesen höchsten Ausdruck zu finden so what  Ich
möchte damit argumentieren, was Heidegger
als Metaphysik des
Bösen bezeichnet hat. Ich denke, dass das nicht sehr
hilfreich ist, um seine Position systematisch zu verstehen.
Ich würde also sagen, dass wir
dieses Zitat in einer Weise interpretieren können
, die Art hat  sozusagen auf zwei
Ebenen,
also gibt es unbewusst gegebene Wünsche erster Ordnung und
es gibt die Möglichkeit der
Selbstbestätigung, die eine Art
Reflexivität wäre, die wir als zweite bezeichnen könnten, oder
Offenbarungen wie Ryan, wie es nach Gott tat,
und es gibt eine andere Vorstellung  das
hilft Shelling, sich zu versöhnen und bereits
verrückt zu sein, in gewisser Weise gegen
Mir im Determinismus bestimmt zu sein und einen
verständlichen Fatalismus zu vermeiden, nur
durch das Naturgesetz bestimmt zu sein, und er
nannte diese Vorstellung höhere Notwendigkeit, von der
er sagt, dass hohe Notwendigkeit unbekannt bleibt,
die gleich weit entfernt ist
Kontingenz im Determinismus und aus
Zwang oder äußerer Bestimmung,
die eher einer inneren Notwendigkeit
entspringt  das Wesen der
in der Witwe selbst so wirkenden Notwendigkeit innere
Notwendigkeit darf nach Beschuss nicht mit dem verwechselt
werden, was man nicht
reine praktische Vernunft oder den reinen
Willen nennen kann, denn diese Art von Willen wäre
nicht im Rätsel und in der Witwe, sondern
gerecht  etwas, das
allgemein durch die Forderung des Sittengesetzes strukturiert
ist und das Teilen gegen Kann nicht, wie ich
ihn lese, betont die Individualität des
Willens, die jedoch in einer ganz
besonderen besonderen Weise bestimmt ist,
er nennt es höhere Notwendigkeit, und das
führt mich zu meiner  Der letzte Punkt, der
Harry Frankfurt ist, den ich
Willensnotwendigkeit ISM nenne, und es ist sehr,
sehr interessant, dass Harry Frankfurt
aus denselben Gründen kritisierte
, die Reinhold unmittelbar
nach seiner zweiten Kritik kritisierte, also
sagt Frankfort, Zitat Kant argumentiert, dass jemand,
dessen Verhalten lediglich motiviert ist  seine
eigenen persönlichen Interessen sind zwangsläufig
heteronom, was die Person interessiert,
ist eine kontingente Selbstverständlichkeit, die von ihr
bestimmt wird  Umstände,
auf die Kant keinen Einfluss hat, versteht Kant darunter
, dass persönliche
Interessen nicht integraler Bestandteil
des Willens einer Person sind. Sie sind seiner Ansicht nach
zusätzlich abenteuerlich, sie hängen nicht
vollständig von den Personen
und dem Willenscharakter ab, sondern zumindest
teilweise von Ursachen  die logisch
außerhalb davon liegen, also kritisiert er Khans
Darstellung aus den gleichen Gründen, die meiner
Meinung nach Reinhold und Schelling getan haben.
Hier ist eine weitere Kritik an Khans
Konzept des reinen, rein bestimmten
Willens, sagt Franklin, Zitat, der reine Wille
hat keinerlei Individualität, in welcher er auch immer
identisch ist  jeder und seine Beziehungen
sind überall genau gleich, d.
h. der reine Wille ist durchaus
unpersönlich, die Befehle, die er erlässt,
werden von niemandem besonders bestimmt, um
zu versuchen, diese Individualität zu bewahren
, die seiner Meinung nach Kant nicht
bewahren konnte und Frankfurt als ich  lies ihn
genau so versucht und hier ist die
lösung von Andrew Franco also eine
sehr ähnlich zu dem, was Schelling vorgeschlagen hat,
er sagt, dass eine Person, die dem Willen unterliegt,
eine Notwendigkeit findet, dass sie so
handeln muss, wie sie es tut
eine solche Situation
legt die Tatsache,
dass er einer Willensnotwendigkeit unterliegt, in der Regel nicht so aus,
als sei er überhaupt passiv, wenn man sich einbildet, dass
die Willensnotwendigkeit sie
durch ihr eigenes Verhalten zu hilflosen Zuschauern macht,
ja vielleicht sogar neigt  darin
sowohl ihre Autonomie als auch ihre
Willensstärke zu sehen, so ist diese Art von
Willensnotwendigkeit nach
Harry Frankfort kontingent, schließt
also unsere Willensfreiheit nicht aus und
so ist hier meiner Meinung nach ein Ausweg aus
diesem Dilemma  des verständlichen Fatalismus
oder eines natürlichen Determinismus, nämlich einer
Art kontingenten Willens und
Notwendigkeit  ist jenseits von Indifferentismus
verständlicher Fatalismus und empirischer
Nester Determinismus